the top thing that people should be
walking away with is is basically the
inspiration and what are they going to
do in their everyday life to become
better people I mean that's what these
laureates were um they were incredible
people that did incredible things and
people can do that it daily in their
lives another alarm on the one public
akasha in europa league so how low in
the tool it is a Florida levantas has
hunted a kind of this though heard on
high in a buffoon an hour on her fortune
see an important Horan co-plaintiff
watauga leave it all when Allah rockso
mater luna publican yeah of all uppity
izveni at for me a big joe torre ability
into sierra degree ball through Santa
strong Ferguson malorum he'll be Scalia
by more wrong auto water put them
captain of the younger commanding a
cheeky rod volume you see I'm having in
a Gangnam easier or a real deity advance
before that Konoha buda interact with
tiered cannot be a beauty me later for
me of intra gear dilemmas for or build
Republic assets t problem listening so
you have see rocks alone things will be
telomere inverted Nahanni or more along
as a liar Rhonda dial hacia all this
permanent law school available Missy at
board the present here Alfred Nobel who
Hans little yarn in freeing us carry
keys to our yearly FML among a good
angles from two till their songs and
collect anonymous on mobile please and
mobile pissed organiz cavity at the DRS
you take a 10 mile final thing oh dear
the Norfolk alert in Idaho and wrapped
in stroganoff and a general Freneau
beldo no se toca mistaken smoke
solidarity khalid el caso bearitones at
the UN extreme complex okok so kind of a
meal out there
mayor mayor theo tvt at the loop take
the loop feeling are you are home now
lt's a poor like I'm Ashley at them
vill- and an incompletely avail- and
Stroke a lake so most of Allah and he'll
the interactivity it's almost gonna
ambulance activity at so dear beef event
they are made in the Messiah F event
except at Jessica not to dl of the
higher millet oblique tempo e blom ion
proton quotient is a blah miglia
Philippa man at eskevar millet FFM
tomahawk so desk Athena's little bit
more little league field I have really
high expectations this is my third time
coming here one time specifically to see
the nobel museum so what I expect when I
come into a museum like this is how it's
going to change me personally these
individuals have are so inspirational
and I want to come out feeling like I've
changed like I'm ready to take on the
world to do amazing things like these
Lords have done
I